الى جورجيا يبدو ان الان الان المباراه
كلها تتجه الى هناك خلال الاسابيع المقبله
سوف تتجه الى هناك بالتاكيد حتى اجراء
دوره الاعاده دوره الاعاده التي ستجرى كما
قلنا سيخوضها المرشحان رافاييلوج وهيرش
الوكر اعاده طبعا ستكون على مقعد مجلس
الشيوخ في السادس من ديسمبر وذلك لتقارب
الاصوات الشديد بينهما السبب في ذلك هو ان
هذا الرجل المنتمي للحزب الليبرتاري اسمه
تشيز اوليفر هذا الرجل دخل السباق وحصل
على اثنين بالمئه من الاصوات بالتالي حرم
المرشحات همم المرشحين الرئيسيين من
الوصول الى نسبه 50 في المئه وهي الحاسمه
لنتائج الانتخابات للفوز بهذا المقاطع من
الان وحتى جوله الاع عدسه تكون جورجيا محط
الانظار والاهتمام الاكبر لكن لماذا اذا
فاز الجمهوريون في نيفادا وهو اكثر
سيناريو مرجح سيكون قد وصلوا الى 50 مقعدا
في مجلس الشيوخ بالتالي ستحقق لهم
الاغلبيه وجورجيا هي التي ستحقق لهم
الاغلبيه في هذا السيناريو على
الديمقراطيين التاكد من الفوز
بيرزونا للوصول الى 49
مقعدا ثم خلط منافسه شرسه على جورجيا
للوصول الى الرقم 50 او المقعد 50 بعد ذلك
يعود الوضع لما كان عليه قبل هذه
الانتخابات النصفيه
جمهوريه وخمسون ديمقراطيه وصوت مرجح لكسر
الجنود سيكون في يد الحزب الديمقراطي لمن
لنائبه الرئيس كامله حارس وهي رئيسه مجلس
الشيوخ بحكم
منصب بها